hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his short work on controlling anger
Plutarch through his narrator fundanas
who's recalling his own struggles with
and not completely conquering anger but
certainly at least arriving at the point
of being able to control it is going to
give us a number of different
considerations and we could call them
even techniques for anger management and
one of the most interesting ones that is
not unique to Plutarch but actually was
used by others in the ancient period is
often called bringing before the eyes
meaning you have observed other people's
anger and now you think about what your
own anger is going to look like and you
know there's a lot of different
components to this as we're going to see
so you have to develop a full picture of
what you as the out of control angry
person look like and this will actually
help to control anger because of the
other emotions and Reflections that it
produces you think oh I don't want to be
like that that's gross that's scary
that's off-putting that's bad and
there's a lot of adjectives that we're
going to see Plutarch using so you begin
by observing others and he starts with
this metaphor or analogy he says that I
began to observe the emotion in others
just as the Spartans used to observe in
the hellots what a thing drunkenness is
so if you don't know the halots were
essentially a slave class that the
Spartans ruled over and actually
horribly abused I mean sometimes they
they would just kill them as part of an
initiation and they made them do
basically all of the menial work and so
they would take their children
and have them observe these hellots
enjoying themselves they'd get them in a
wine let them get all drunk and then
they'd be like see don't be like those
people over there look how gross they
are look how out of control they are so
fedonas is saying you know we can do
this with respect to anger and so he
says just as Hippocrates says that the
most severe disease is that in which the
countenance or the face of the sufferer
is most unlike itself I observed that
those who are transported controlled you
know driven by anger have some radical
changes in their own appearance and what
are these well he actually rattles off
the general classes so there's the face
the oppsis right when people get angry
they do things like they Furrow their
brows or you know they make a gur face
right sometimes people call this a war
face but you know it's really an angry
face and you think of your own
experience in seeing so many other
people angry at others angry at you
angry and and television shows and
things like that so the face
color
um you know it depends on what skin
color we have there's really two main
reactions blood goes into our face and
sometimes even our ears you know and
things like that people used to be able
to tell that I was getting angry because
my ears would turn red because I have
you know very fair skin
blood can also Flow Away from the face
as it does the extremities when you're
getting ready to fight somebody right
and so you might become pale or ashy or
uh you know an olive skin can turn kind
of yellowish we can also have all these
other kinds of of color reactions as
well and then he says gate is translated
as gate body smell literally the way in
which we're moving around so our body
language our posture our attitudes the
we might even say the tenor and tonality
of our muscular system changes when we
get angry some people get very tense
other people are ready to fight you know
so that's a key thing people walk
differently you know they're determined
gate when they're angry I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go talk to the manager or
something like that and then voice and
there's going to be a lot of different
things happening with the voice the
phony right uh what it is that we're
we're talking with and so you know he's
going to give a whole bunch of examples
of this
so he talks about appearing terrible and
deranged to my friends and my wife and
my daughters not merely Savage and
unfamiliar to their sight because of all
of these these things you know posture
face voice but speaking with so harsh
and rough a voice as were others of my
intimate friends whom I used to meet at
times when anger had made them unable to
preserve their character bearing or
Grace of speech or their winning an
affable manner so when we get angry we
turn into you know kind of savage jerks
we raise our voices our voices get
harsher the tone of our voice changes
we're no longer at least in appearance
the same person that we were
um I'm going to go on a little bit
further here and give some more examples
you know
you could be in a state which nature did
not intend with one features all
distorted right
and that's uh you know plays a
significant role in how we look
um he talks about Distortion of the face
in other places anger puffing up and
distending the face in an Unbecoming way
utters a voice more ugly and unpleasant
so you know we've got a good picture of
what angry people look like now we can
actually form a image a picture an icon
uh you know iconot to Pathos is what
we're coming up with a image or picture
of that emotion of anger in ourselves in
the people who we ourselves are and so
he says that well when I did this formed
for myself a picture of that it was
uncomfortable to think that I should
appear this way to the people that I
care about
friends family uh wife children right
and
this can be a very helpful way of making
us get back in control of our anger and
he brings up two interesting uh cases so
one is Gaius gracas who is a important
Roman Statesman and he would get angry
uh he was an orator he was severe in his
disposition and spoke too passionately
so he had a servant behind him playing a
pitch pipe something like a recorder you
know we could call it a flute whatever
you want to have it and so
um he had a pitch pipe made and his
servant used to stand behind him as he
spoke and gave a decorous and gentle
tone which was a reminder it enabled
gracas to remit his loud cries and
remove from his voice the harsh and
passionate elements so he might have
actually been angry but with his servant
behind him you know playing this nice
note he'd be like oh yeah yeah I have to
watch it when I'm talking to people here
in the Forum so that's an interesting
one and then interestingly fondana says
you know imagine if you had a friend to
hold up a mirror as you're getting angry
like people do after bathing right they
bathing was like a big
not all day but you know it's a
significant thing it wasn't just hopping
in the shower popping back out and when
we do that you know most of us live in
places where we have mirrors and we're
like yeah how's my hair you know do I
need to trim my beard need any makeup or
anything like that and we're looking at
ourselves we're seeing what we look like
sometimes we're happy sometimes we're
not we're like oh I'm putting on weight
oh I'm too skinny all those sorts of
things now imagine if when we're angry
we had somebody like next to us who
brings up a mirror and writers were like
you know I I are angry you know making a
face and saying horrible things we see
ourselves in that mirror
and we're like oh
I I don't like that is that is that
actually what I look like I mean it's
not inconceivable in the present with
the kind of technology that we have I
mean think about you could easily take
your cell phone and just click record
with a video and you see yourself right
there just like taking a selfie imagine
if we actually had you know uh Google
Glass or whatever other you know silly
things are being designed for eyewear
this would actually be a non-silly
application of it you've got your your
you know special glasses on you're
starting to get angry at somebody and
then like there's like a little camera
maybe like a drone hovering by you and
it shoots you an image of just what you
look like and you hear in your ears your
own voice like maybe with a five second
delay talking like a jerk
would that actually be helpful and he
says that
um
this actually would help me out why
seeing oneself in a state which nature
did not attend it's going against human
nature in a way with all of these
features distorted contributes in no
small way
to discrediting and it's interesting the
word there for discrediting is actually
the word for slander the Ebola right
saying bad things about somebody in this
case it happens to be true your anger is
bad for you so you know this is actually
useful you you look at it and you're
like oh that's not not good
and you've got an example here about
Athena as well and Marcis
um but what's what's going on here so
anger puffs up and distends the face you
know
um and then he's got this thing about
the face and The Voice
but also what's being said so now we're
going Beyond just we could call it mere
physical appearance and the tone the
content the as we sometimes say mere
semantics which is not never mere
semantics of what's going on what the
claims people are making the things that
they're saying are coming up as well and
he's got a great metaphor here
when the sea is disturbed by the winds
and casts up tangle and seaweed right
you know if you've ever been by a lake
you see all the bits and pieces floating
around he says there's certain kind of
words that we say when we're angry what
are they in temperate
right uh bitter pikra now bitterness is
something that we taste but it's used as
a master metaphor in the ancient
Mediterranean world for anger and
harshness and you know kind of
disposition that we don't like and then
vulgar spermologa words Rhema right is
what we we utter we say to to people
without even really thinking about it
and then he says um
the things that we say
defile us the speakers
and make us look bad they fill us with
disrepute is how it's translated here
they're shameful if we think about the
things that we say when we're angry when
we're later on calm we're like oh
shouldn't have said that I really went
too far that was that was not me
but in a certain sense yes that is you
and he goes out and he says what is the
general assumption about these things
um people have had these traits these
ideas these ways of looking at things
inside them the whole time and now the
inner nature is being revealed to
everybody else anger shows the person as
they genuinely are inside he says laid
bare by their anger brought to light you
could say right
um unhidden even you know it's Anna
kalupto menus
and so he says that because of the
lightest of things a mere word as Plato
says they incur the heaviest of
punishments what is the heaviest of
punishments being considered to be a
certain kind of person a person who is
ugly a person who is shameful how else
does he describe it he's got this great
concluding thing
boy enemies right we treat people who
should be our friends as if they're our
enemies
um
right bad speakers literally people who
say awful things slanderous is a good
way and also uh malicious kako atheists
Taco atheist doesn't just mean doing bad
things but having being bad inhabit
being bad and disposition and he says we
appear this way dokuntes in
um Greek you know we appear to be this
kind of person so if we think about how
anger does in fact affect our own
appearance by looking at other people
and then kind of extrapolating to
ourselves or even using images of
ourselves when we're angry if we're
lucky enough for other people to take
those we can realize that we don't want
to be like that why not because it's bad
it looks bad and it makes us act and
appear to be other than we would like to
think of ourselves as being so this can
be a very useful technique for gradually
developing some measure of control over
one's own anger